Speaker 1: Well, my disappointment with podcaster
Joe Rogan continues to grow.
The latest is that Rogan called Donald Trump's
press secretary, Kayleigh MCENANY, the Michael
Jordan of press secretaries.
The truth, of course, could not be more different.
Kayleigh MCENANY, one of the most dishonest
press secretaries that I have ever covered
in this, dates back to the George W Bush administration,
quite frankly.
Hard to find a more dishonest press secretary.
Now, unfortunately, I think what Rogan is
falling prey to is sometimes people sound
really confident, but the things they say
are absurd.
This is sometimes called Ben SHAPIRO syndrome,
where people will very confidently say things
that are wrong, dishonest, absurd, pathetic,
not based, in fact.
And Kayleigh MCENANY did that.
She sounded very confident, but she didn't
really answer questions.
And she lied absolutely all the time.
So this is part of the continued disappointment
with what has been going on with Rogan.
And again, speculation is he moved to Texas.
Reports are he sometimes hangs around with
extremists like Republican Governor Greg Abbott
and others.
And there may be some sort of I don't know
about audience capture, but maybe like a social
circle capture of sorts.
Here is Rogan talking about Kayleigh MCENANY.
Speaker 3: She was a propagandist.
I mean, when she's working for the White House,
she's this person that, you know, answers
questions and most of it the hard questions
are all by peter doocy on Fox.
Speaker 1: So by the way, here he's criticizing
Jen Psaki who is Biden's former press secretary
who I have to tell you by and large was a
more honest press secretary.
Of course.
Of course, they all spin.
But in terms of out and out lies, Psaki was
dramatically more honest than any of Trump's
press secretaries.
Speaker 3: It was he was like the only guy
that was like like pushing back against her.
And she just flat out lied.
And not just one occasion, multiple occasions.
I mean, maybe they had a narrative that they
told her.
Maybe these are talking parts.
Maybe that's her job.
But it's a weird job in the beginning, right,
to begin with, because it's a job where you're
not even asking the president.
You're asking this White House press secretary.
Yeah.
So there's a person, you know, and the only
one who's good at the girl.
MCENANY It's her name, Kayleigh.
MCENANY, The one who worked for Trump.
That lady was a fucking ass.
And that lady had, like, binders with like,
footnotes and anyone say.
So I'm sure that's interesting because actually
CNN said this and right.
Speaker 1: Those were all distortions.
And this is the problem with optics.
And it's really sad you you wouldn't necessarily
think and in Rogan's defense, not that I need
to defend him.
Maybe he didn't really watch an entire press
briefing to understand that the binders and
the confident response is it was built on
nothing.
It was just smoke and mirrors.
Speaker 3: And she would like quote it back
to them and stuff it in their face.
That lady's the best ever at that job.
She's the Michael Jordan of White House press
secretaries.
Speaker 1: She's yeah.
I mean, obviously that it's really disappointing
to hear that because a critical thinker would
say let's separate let's separate substance
from tone and delivery.
Let's separate the facts or lack thereof from
the optics.
And I mean, listen, Kayleigh MCENANY promulgated
the big lie.
Is there a bigger lie than Trump actually
won the 2020 election and she lied endlessly
beyond that and defended the indefensible?
Everything that Trump was doing, everything
Trump did, she defended from the, you know,
COVID laced joyride with Secret Service around
the hospital.
Like, I couldn't I could spend an hour giving
you the list.
There was nothing she would not defend.
So when we say she was great at her job, she
sounded confident, which is something unfortunately
lots of right wingers do when they say things
that are completely untrue and bogus.
And of course, you can just go back and find
all of the different things that she lied
about.
MCENANY made weeks of Prescott Press statements
about Trump never downplayed coronavirus.
Trump literally said, We have 15 cases which
will soon be zero.
There is no bigger downplaying than when you
end up with 100 million cases.
There's no bigger downplaying than that.
And she did that for weeks and weeks and weeks.
She made the same false claims about the Mueller
report that Trump would make.
It exonerated him.
It literally did not exonerate him is that
we can not clear him of obstruction.
The 2020 election lies constantly exaggerating
number.
I'm not going to bore you with it, but the
point is hard to find a more dishonest press
secretary.
And sadly, Rogan seems to have fallen
for it.